comme vous l'avez dit j'étais marin
marin qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
engagement volontaire
de protéger et servir mon pays mon pays
qui est la france bien sûr fabrice a
fait le même choix en tant qu on a été
amené à partir sur différents théâtres
d'opérations des bons des mauvais c'est
pas le problème aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que je suis plus militaire et on
se rend compte que un pays se fait
attaquer par un par un état qui
s'autoproclament un petit peu je vais te
prendre pour te manger et nous notre
décision aujourd'hui elle est de
reprendre nos valeurs nos valeurs qui
sont patriotiques mais de défense de
l'europe
pour protéger l'ensemble de la
population
j'aimerais quand même faire une petite
correction
je m'en étais
de même corps explique la première
journée a vu les critiques a même fait
bonne que des corrections
contrairement à ce que l'on a pu lire
sur les réseaux sociaux nous n'allons
pas là-bas pour faire la guerre d'accord
à nous à nous avons
tous des compétences et des
connaissances dans le domaine c'est ce
que nous allons apporter là bas
nous voulons soutenir une population
aider des femmes des enfants qui se
retrouve seul aux frontières alors que
leurs maris et leurs pairs sont partis
et des leurres patrick demain
s'il se passe la même chose en france le
souhait que je veux et que je j'aimerais
c'est que d'autres pays fassent la même
chose donc la 2 et le deuxième point
alors fabrice sera un plus à même d'en
parler parce que lui ne sera plus sur ce
phénomène là beaucoup de médias on a vu
dans les journaux nous ont dit oui vous
allez partir à la guerre prendre une
arme non la guerre c'est quoi parce que
l'on entende partout la guerre c'est
d'abord une aide humanitaire c'est ce
que l'on va faire si je doit
comptabiliser le entre les heures de
combat et les heures d'humanitaires que
j'ai fait dans la marine elles sont plus
humanitaire que combat que ce soit sur
tous les théâtres d'opérations qui a pu
avoir lieu mais mes compatriotes qui ont
été militaire le savez aussi bien que
moi voire peut-être même mieux donc
aujourd'hui le départ il est dans un
principe humanitaire et on a besoin
d'énormément d'elle donc
je suis français je suis européen je
vais aider un peuple de cette tyrannie
russe mais comme j'en ai envie
je posais une question bien entendu à
fabrice pas pourquoi avez vous décidé de
partir et con quand vous êtes dit je
vais y aller moi je vais partir du 6
entre 7 et 10 jours d'accord juste le
temps de préparer les derniers
préparatifs avant de partir au niveau de
la famille qui sont pas au courant
d'ailleurs on peut l'apprendre ce soir
ils vont l'apprendre lama temps ils vont
là bas ils vont l'apprendre ce soir la
protection de vos parents tous avec
personne n'est pas de tradition de
courant ni mes frères et soeurs ni ma
famille personne au courant de mon
engagement d'accord de votre dix matches
choix que j'ai fait pourquoi vous avez
décidé de partir parce que je suis un
ancien légionnaire tout simplement et
tout simplement j'ai des compétences qui
peut être requise
là bas ils voient les bombardements ma
spécialité c'était des ménages ouais
donc moi j'ai pas je vais pas faire
forcément l'humanitaire mais si je peux
apporter ma formation de jardin au
niveau du déminage là bas je ferai quand
je pense que c'est un c'est ce qu'il
faut c'est ce qu'il faut vous avez
l'impression de les aider l'ukraine ou
de défendre la france en y allant ces
deux choses différentes deux choses
différentes et c'est même chose
moi je vais pas défendre ni l'un ni
l'autre je veux pas que les enfants qui
de 15 ans qui prête mes propres enfants
fait qu'ils partent sur un terrain
qu'ils connaissent pas les armes qu'ils
connaissent pas les grenades qui ne
connaissent rien du tout en fait ça
c'est pas bon quand tu vois aux
informations tout ce qu'ils nous disent
sûres
sur tout ce qui se passe des parents
comme il rejoint notre ami et là
il ya plein de choses qu'on le voit et
les gens ne connaissent rien mais ils
partent quand même défendre leur pays
actuellement il va le faire une légion
le légionnaire a alors commencé à se
passer parce que donc vous partez vous
partez avec des gens de différents pays
ou que des français devant le choix il
ya pour le moment moi je parle je sais
pas toi manger on a des contacts privés
d'accord donc j'ai eu contact avec
l'ambassade notamment d'autres personnes
également les français des français donc
les aliments mais sur un départ français
d'accord très bien le danemark qui est
déjà parti les allemands qui sont déjà
partis reste l'angleterre également j'ai
eu vent de certains américains qui sont
déjà parties d'accord sans confirmation
est ce que vous savez comment ça se
passe et risque donc tout le monde se
réunit qui donne les ordres comment ça
se passe quand ces réponses dit on
arrive en ukraine déjà vous il ya des
gens qui vous accueille là bas qui vous
amène sur un lieu de fête il ya tous les
logiciels et les soutient dans un
premier temps il faut rallier la pologne
d'accord j'ai pu le nom de la ville
m'excuserai à kovy pas comment il faut
rallier la pologne et de là bas ils vont
demander nos spécialités d'accord ce que
moi je porte une parole et une est un et
1 et je demande à tous ceux qui pourront
nous aider parce que l'un des parts
militaire n'est pas que un départ armée
il ya des enfants il ya des femmes il ya
besoin d'amener moi ma femme m'a vu et
déjà intégré les armes à la barre n'ont
prévu cette interview prévue mais il
faut aussi que nous quand on parte d'ici
on parte avec ce qu'on a besoin pour
survivre là bas mais ils ont besoin de
choses il ya des femmes et des enfants
qui sont partis comme en sortant du
studio avec rien pourquoi ma femme a
déjà préparé un sac avec des enfants des
affaires d'enfants de bébé pour le
ramener là bas ça c'est le premier geste
qui va ya voir après si on arrive là bas
ils nous disent bat mathieu fabrice vous
avez une connaissance de l'armement eux
ils savent pas faire allez leur
apprendre c'est une aide bien sûr tu
n'aides le port de larmes sur place il
faut bien se mettre en tête je pense que
beaucoup l'ont pas forcément compris
gilles je pense que l'a très bien
compris on va arriver sur place on peut
pas aller à kiev maintenant on n'est pas
des rambo c'est ça on est là pour vous
allez rester reste en pologne non mais
je pense qu'on va devoir aller en
ukraine hier d'accord la frontière et
puisque aller assez grande bien sûr elle
est allée assez grande on va devoir
aller en ukraine c'est la protection
civile
c'est des choses auxquelles on a appris
à faire et on saura le faire et on sera
à prendre à d'autres personnes à le
faire c'est très important juste mais la
vive de la ville de lviv vrai que je
pense qu'on ne dépassera jamais d'accord
d'accord quoi parce que l'armée russe
on sait pas encore ce qu'ils ont
derrière la tête mais il nous
empêcherons d'arriver à kiel et ils
empêcheront toute personne de
s'approcher de cette ville c'est ça donc
et nous on a pas on n'a pas d'avion on
n'a pas de radio on y va même pas sous
le pavillon français on y va sous le
pavillon humain exactement c'est ça
alors est ce que il ya plein de gens qui
disent que vous êtes prêts à donner
votre vie pour pour cette mission parce
que j'imagine bien que reste il ya quand
même un risque
fabrice énormément de risque
c'est les risques que je connais ça
depuis maintenant plus de quinze ans
quand je vous ai dit à la légion on a
des risques c'est pareil on part sous
quelle identité là votre avis
non pas mon identité nationale avec taqa
j'avais une autre identité alba à
nettoyer une identité l'étranger en fait
ok d'accord donc repartir au combat pour
aider des gens dans le besoin je le
ferai par contre j'ai un cri d'alarmé
aussi à passer ici c'est que quand on
est sur les réseaux sociaux on voit les
gens les jeunes des gamins de 20 ans 18
ans qui sont en train de crier haut et
fort comme ça moi je vais partir au
combat amélie on n'est pas dans une
vidéo en fait on n'est pas sur call of
duty battlefield
on prend un rpg ou quoi que ce soit pin
up on y va on tire là bas dans le dos
non il faut y aller réfléchi faut y
aller avec un coeur vous avez vous avez
des informations sur ce qui se passe là
bas enfin vous avez pris le maximum
d'informations avant de partir moi je
les ai pris quelques unes c'est en train
de se sent train de se charger il ya des
gens qui sont arrivés ce matin en
pologne maintenant je pense que dans les
prochaines heures peut-être dans la nuit
on aura des infos un peu plus précise à
savoir que tout départ de personnes de
france ou d'ailleurs en arrivant sur
place
seront enrôlés dans une armée un petit
peu perdues donc il faudra faire très
attention à ça